the impeachment hearings go public this
week as the battle over witnesses is
giving us a glimpse of what to expect in
the days to come
three administration officials set to
testify before Congress in live
televised public hearings two on
Wednesday and one on Friday the
Republicans have their own wish list of
interviewees demanding to hear from
hunter Biden and the anonymous
whistleblower whose complaint launched
the impeachment inquiry house until
chairman Adam Schiff however is making
it clear some witnesses are a no-go
he says hearing from the whistleblower
would be quote redundant and unnecessary
the White House sending sounding off on
that
there are public hearings starting this
week but clearly they're not going to be
public because we don't get to have
anybody from our side
out there to tell our side of the
stories meanwhile Democrats are pushing
back on that list they say having hunter
Biden testify is unrelated we want to
stay focused on the Ukraine call and
having hunter Biden come in is unrelated
to the Ukraine call and so that becomes
irrelevant I don't think he's an
appropriate witness and not only that
but I think that the reason they're
calling for these witnesses these new
witnesses is because they want to make a
spectacle and a circus out of this
entire proceeding the President of the
United States demanding extorting a
vulnerable country to do his political
bidding to go after his opponent has
nothing to do with Joe Biden executing
the foreign policy and I states and some
in the media are offering Democrats
advice on how they should handle the
hearings if this could can be dramatized
so that our diplomats struggling against
the president and feel like soldiers in
a battlefield and their commander
abandoned them and if that gets through
I think that changes the stakes they
wanted Murray Ivanovich there because
I'm told she cried in her testimony and
they essentially want someone who's
going to be emotional to say I was a
victim of the president trying to do
this for his own political game and just
before this show started
so we haven't had a chance to read all
of it there was another batch of
testimony released this is a transcript
from Laura Cooper Laura Cooper worked at
the Department of Defense and one of her
jobs was to get the aid to Ukraine so
that's out there you can look it up we
will probably have it on our website but
we haven't read the whole thing because
it was
probably riveting but we were talking
about other things in the green room yes
and I don't care about anymore
transcripts I happen to agree that
they're right almost all of this stuff
is redundant and unnecessary but I do
like meet the press they prove what
we've always known that this is a two
team effort you have the media and the
Democrats one is the team the other ones
the cheerleaders sometimes they they
switch roles talking about the female
ambassador that that it's a really
positive thing that she cried and that
she's cried before and that possibly she
could cry again and that is really help
that could help them I'm he had to think
about how gross that is that they that
they're hoping she cries in order to
manipulate the viewers because they know
this is thin gruel I don't have any
facts it's all opinions it's an orgy of
opinion if a producer said to me before
the five and said you know if you get
Dana or Emily to cry on the five it's
gonna be great TV that person would be
fired if we got you to cry oh one has
made me cry in number time I usually
went to the bathroom in the breaks and I
cry in somebody I cried my sweater but I
go back to this dumb question that I had
on Friday which was if there was a
prosecutor who vows to charge you with a
crime before it's committed how could
that prosecutor be near you during an
inquiry are you look you look at ship
and the dams
they've all been bowing to a peach for
three years are they biased how they
greeted this whole thing they
reverse-engineer it why should we be
allowed to listen to them what should we
want it's an interesting thing Jesse
just reading about the founding fathers
and how they thought about impeachment
they put it in the Congressional branch
not the judicial branch because
impeachment is more of a political
decision and there's not a real clear
definition of high crimes and
misdemeanors I mean you could sort of
try to come up with it and say we could
all agree on this but there's not
agreement on it at all I agree with your
point Dana that the founding fathers
would not have wanted the president to
be impeached in this instance very very
very well articulated
to all of America heard it's working and
I do this whole scandal feels microwave
to me it feels like Russia was hot and
this just feels like a bunch of
leftovers
I like the witness list though it's a
good list they're not going to be able
to bring any of these guys here hunter
Biden I love that hunter Biden is
irrelevant hunter Biden is at the center
of this whole Venn diagram right you
take hunter Biden out of here and there
is no story so of course they'll rig it
then they won't let him testify
alexandra chalupa will testify if
Republicans get their way I love her
name it reminds me of Taco Bell she was
the DNC woman who went to Ukraine and
got dirt on mana Ford and Trump and gave
it to Hillary okay seems relevant to
this whole thing and then the
whistleblower they want to testify
I think he should testify because right
now he's trying to steal 60 million
people's votes in the dark and he's
already worked with Brennan and Biden we
know that whole thing it's a scam Obama
prosecuted more whistleblowers in his
administration than all other u.s.
presidential administrations in history
combined you breathed on a whistle and
he charged you with espionage that's how
bad it was now the facts of the timeline
here are very interesting all right he
has the president until September 30th
to give this ad to Ukraine he gets it
out on September 11 three weeks before
the deadline so we give our ally aid and
Joe Biden is not investigated remember
that they get the aid and we get nothing
in return
the Democrats want that to be an
impeachable offense good luck with that
well that isn't interesting though the
timeline of like when the aid then was
released because we know that the White
House was informed there was a
whistleblower complaint we know that
Congress was starting to get antsy about
it and so basically they were like
excuse us White House knock knock
there's problem here is there a problem
and then the egg gets released and
everyone's like there's no harm no foul
well I mean that's obviously done under
pressure but the the crime had already
been committed the crime was essentially
trying to force the government to give
you dirt on your political opponent by
withholding the money because the money
had been held up to that point and the
question was why was it being held up
and that's what led to the knocking that
you described Dina the one there's no
crime there is a crime there is no crime
there is if you haven't stated one crime
early that you are using us money as
president to try to get dirt from a
foreign government on in there it's not
in there no one's got dirt there they
searching corruption but here's the
thing I think that you know first of all
to your point Greg the phone call took
place in June June 25th I think is the
exact date so wasn't that people were
trying to impeach him before that on
this call that call started in June and
teach which started before he was even
became president you're talking about
just kind of people didn't like him but
you're saying this is a specific real
incident and with regard to the
witnesses I mean clearly elections have
consequences and Democrats control the
House of Representatives they get to
decide who's called and this was the
case with Benghazi as I recall so I
means the same thing when the
Republicans had control so to my mind
you can even forget the witnesses
because the president over the weekend
he said to Republicans nothing nothing
was wrong this was a perfect call don't
say that
oh yeah there might be some problems
with extortion and bribery but we
shouldn't impeach the press gets a there
was nothing wrong now you talk about
outrageous that's the president say
anything about extortion or bribery but
what about let me ask so so the
Republicans are asking for their
witnesses Adam Schiff gets to say yea or
nay right if you're in a court this is
not a court of law right this is
Congress but what is what is the best
tactic if you are Republicans to try to
get those witnesses to testify I think
at this point their best option is the
court of public opinion and it's
interesting right now what you guys just
played out is exactly that what we
should be noting which is that up until
this week the trigger words were a quid
pro quo and all of a sudden now the
words extortion and bribery are being
thrown Collision times had 33 brighter
saying don't call it quid pro quo
anymore call it call it what it really
is and I just have to say that this what
we're also seeing play out is exactly
that questionable part that when the the
process rules were voted on that the
Democrats had that ability to deny the
production of witnesses to denial lines
of questioning and don't forget if they
feel the president is being
uncooperative
in any of the
six investigations than they can levy
those appropriate remedies which
includes denying requests final point
for a second that again for the ninth
time this year the Dow Jones closed at
an all-time high
so while all of this is going on the
American public the consumer public is
still having a ball